[Music]
all right
omar atef okay let's go e4
guys this is all going on youtube in
fact several videos are out already
all right we're gonna go knight f3 and
we have been playing the italian which
is which is an opening that
emphasizes classical principles that's
why i'm playing it
d6 now we have already faced this move
and you guys
those of you who remember what do we do
here what have we decided to do here
to control the center what have we
decided to do to control the center
not d4 immediately we want to prepare d4
d4 is a good move
but we want to prepare it how do we
prepare d4
how do we prepare e4 yeah we want to go
c3 d4 is fine but we like to occupy the
center with our pawns
now also it um
it poses it remember in a previous game
we played the move queen b3 so when he
gets his bishop out of c8 if you've seen
the morphe opera game
you know that these pawns okay so the
previous guy did the same thing we take
it
ruining his structure in front of his
king queen b3 by the way is a fork but
it's not a good one
because black has queen c8 so let's just
go d4 let's not
do anything crazy he takes we take we
have a beautiful center
he has a weak king we have an advantage
he goes e5 all right now according to
our principle that we have formulated
and this gets a little bit complicated
do we want to close the center
are we closing the center based on our
discussion two games ago
actually we do not well we can closing
the center i would probably play and
after the game i will show why
but this game let's practice keeping the
center open
so let's just develop our pieces we can
close the center
which is an exception to the rule but
here we're going to keep it open just to
practice playing with an open center
which you guys actually need more of
don't worry i will explain exactly why
we could have closed the center after
the game now we take with the queen
my guess is a lot of people go c5 in a
position like this a lot of people
not realizing that they're weakening the
square i can guarantee you
probably 50 of players like him will go
c5 no he goes knight f6
what do we do broken monitor thank you
so much
what do we do we castle
nothing to invent here we castle
we don't need to so eve morgan i'll
explain e5 in a moment thank you shaq
why not so he's making a very classic
mistake he's trying to intimidate us
by putting a knight on a square where
it's not actually doing anything thank
you kit for the sub
what do we do do we respond do we react
or do we just keep developing we can
chase the knight away with h3
but i want to show you guys that we can
completely ignore and we don't have to
do anything
just keep developing let's keep
developing bishop f4
also this supports the bond so the queen
h4 doesn't does no longer come
with a maid threat let's keep that train
rolling loving loving it guys thank you
for the support
we don't react now in addition to just
moving the same piece twice
okay and as soon as we do nothing
what do we do now do we move the bishop
do we reactively move the bishop
or do we apply the principle every time
a pawn is moved
we try to understand what weaknesses
have been left behind
thank you thank you for the rook
thank you for the pawn and in addition
his knight is now undefended his king is
wide open
boom boom fork knight undefended
wide open rook i only have a knife do i
even have a fork
basic i'm super basic i don't even have
a fork i just have knives and spoons
but you get the point we need to think
about forks
do we have a fork do we have a fork
we do but not here since the queen goes
to that square boom boom boom
the queen son of john won another sub
thank you so much man
thank you keep it rolling
all right we win the piece
okay ratings are refunded just reminding
you guys
yeah bore 3d of you queen g5 would have
been better because it would have
covered both potential forkable squares
he could have also dropped his knight
onto a defended square he's obviously
still completely lost
because he's down a million pieces i
should not pre-move queen takes g4
because
maybe he'll go queen g6 hoping for that
pre-move he'll play king e7 and after
king e7
we apply another principle never play a
single move automatically unless it is
literally the only move that is forced
always
take a moment to search for better moves
and you guys are amazing
knight d5 check would be a fork and a
much greater fork after king e7
so his only moves are king d8 and king
d7 and he maybe should block the queen
okay so he's busted lenser with 500 bits
that's right
amazing and oh my god and we gotta stop
sir t
bone subscribing with prime holy smokes
you guys
i'm loving this i am loving this
he's stalling that's okay that's okay in
the meantime wasting no time jose
src subscribing with twitch prime he's
disconnected
so i think he is not very happy
our accuracy level so far in these games
has been pretty high and he
he whoa oh my god
g cook 17 29.5 gifted oh my god
oh my god guys sorry i'm screaming but
i'm excited skirmish just gifted 10.
holy smokes what is going on here we
have an explosion
g cook 1729 then skirmin 10 gifted subs
to puddi chulu loves you so wild it's
kuala null i am scrabby
and gm donald trump i joined only
because of
oh my lands oh my lens this is
ridiculous
okay guys the energy has arrived
i can even extend the stream we got wawa
sc gifting we got
tbj with the sub gsw 2017 go warriors
with five more subs and curious
chimpanzee with 200 bits oh my god i
can't even talk about the game stop it
you guys aren't letting me talk about
the game right now oh my lance this is
this is an
overwhelming oh my goodness we're almost
at 2 000.
jacobs123 a sub to nick richardson
okay but let's talk about the game thank
you guys so much i really agree this is
amazing
raider raider rampage priming
twitch prime and this
is percolating we're going crazy okay
so of course of course thank you guys
this would not be possible without this
kind of support
so um the you know the credit belongs to
you guys thank you so much
all right so
the move d6 we have already discussed
is bad because it doesn't develop
anything and it obstructs the
development of the bishop
as we have talked about the main moves
here our bishop c5
and knight f6 there's also the hungarian
variation bishop e7 which is reasonable
it's a little bit passive
but i have played this move myself thank
you guys this is you're making me blush
so d63 and bishop b6 we've already had
this the last guy please help me with
this
with a with a sub thank you for the
three months the last guy played d5
which is actually a very reasonable move
this guy takes the pawn and we take back
now we get the c3 square for the knight
and he goes e5 this is the main moment
in the whole game
let's talk a little bit about how i
decided
not to close the center as a matter of
fact both moves are very very good it
would have been a great idea to close
the center
now bishop g4 where bishop g4 can
somebody who is paying very careful
attention
to the ideas white has in this position
tell me what white does here
what does white actually do here and
this is an idea that we've already seen
before that i actually mentioned
in this game i already mentioned this
this in this game
yeah queen b3 is right so queen b3 is
correct
um because
i'm i'm very happy to hear that super
duper shiny yeah queen b3 is right
it's too early to take on f7 but the
move queen b3 has the same idea now
we're preparing to take on f
and if white black takes on f3 i
mentioned this previously we have this
checkmating mechanism that people should
remember
black does not have any way to guard
both pawns at the same time
in morphe's opera game which is quite
possibly the most famous and the most
overrated game of all time
we have seen uh that sorry morphe
went d e we saw that morphe did
something very very similar he forks the
pawn in the pawn
and um that basically was how the opera
game started it's it's exactly the same
idea
okay so he goes to edd5 now
d5 now we have discussed the principle
that when we have a lead in development
and when we have when your opponent is a
weak king
it is usually not a good idea to close
the center because we make it harder for
ourselves to access
his king we make it harder for ourselves
to
take advantage of our leading
developments but the reality is that
here specifically
we have a maneuver that is so strong
that it actually
justifies it justifies us closing the
center
and it is only because of this maneuver
being possible
that it is fine to close the center as
well so
it's a very concrete moment could
somebody spot what i'm talking about
here
bingo potato for president you deserve a
sub my man
lord adamson knight you 5 look at this
look at this look at this knight
this outpost and that's why you need to
be very attentive to outposts
is going to be a monster it is literally
look at this monstrosity on e6 it's not
letting black castle either way
black literally is paralyzed now we're
gonna go bishop g5 and we're gonna open
up that f-file
and crash through and check my plaque so
actually this is probably
white's best move now if you
are on the receiving end of such a
situation let's look for let's say
you're playing black
damn you allowed a outpost like this to
happen
by accident is there anything that you
can do and be sharky
comment to play with a thousand thank
you so much np sharky
what do you do is it completely lost you
can use what we discussed
undermining you could play c6 and you
can try to undermine
the base of the outpost it doesn't
actually solve black's problems because
here white can kind of ignore him
and the pawn is a little bit weaker
though so this gets a little bit
complicated but if you are on the
receiving end of an outpost
see if you can undermine the piece or
the pawn
that is holding the outpost that is
defending it
okay in order to try to get out of the
situation thank you sufultra
for gifting to patel for president
appreciate it okay
back to reality we decided to keep the
center open
just to practice playing in these kinds
of positions
um okay so for those of you who are
wondering can black take the pawn
you actually cannot this is a good
tactical idea but it doesn't work
because after knight takes d5 if we take
thank you twit max if we take knight 65
then queen takes d5
if we take queen takes e6 then
fork fork for a fork this is a family
fork
and we win the queen so this is a little
bit of calculation
but the knight is retained on e6 okay
so knight c3 is the move
and so he takes d4 knight takes d4
knight 64 queen takes d4
just to remind you guys the move c5
would have made things even worse
because it would have weakened the
square and i want to
use this because we only have time maybe
for one last one after this
to introduce to you the concept of weak
squares i want to talk a little bit
about positional chess and make a small
detour
how do we exploit the weakness of the d5
square
do we put a knight on d5 immediately
could somebody tell me the plan
and why is knight d5 immediately a bad
idea it's a bad idea because we want a
knight on d5 we don't want to trade
pieces on d5 we want the knight to be on
d5 all alone
the merciful sermon beautiful bishop g5
take the knight and stick this beauty on
d5
you can castle first too you might ask
me how did i know to do that
where am i pulling this line up well
guess what when i was about seven or
eight
every single russian schoolboy
is always shown a game uh that is a
very classical game which features
precisely this planet is a game between
smithslav
former world champion soviet union and
rutakovsky a master
it is a game played in 1945 and it is a
game
precisely in which this plan was applied
by smithslav
this position occurred on the board what
do you think smithslav did here
what do you think smithslav did here can
he play an it5
no he can't that's terrible but what do
you do
boom boom
boom and that wins the game because this
knight is
so strong black can take the pawn but
here smith's love can deliver a fork
there's a little tactical justification
basically that is what's missed loved it
everybody has shown this game
you guys might be like daniel
has this ever happened to you have i
ever allowed a knight on t5
uh have i ever allowed a knight to come
to d5 and gotten crushed
i absolutely have i absolutely have
and let me show you guys a good example
of that
let me show you guys a good example of
that i know the cursors go crazy here
but i will
i will flip the game in a moment
got a kamsky one of the most legendary
players of all time literally a famous
fn legend
this is my game against kamsky from the
u.s championship 2017.
i played a ray lopez and guess what
happened to me
what has got to do in this position
bishop g5
now he gets his knight around he takes
any and and he tr look at you have the
components of that plan boom
boom boom okay so it's happened to me
and i got crushed
and this plan is one of the most
classical plans in a lot of different
positions
the outpost specifically on d5 is one
that you have to look for and remember
the plan
of getting rid of the knight on f6 or
whatever is guarding the outpost and
then sticking the knight on the outpost
so i have plenty of games to show you
that that's not the only time
that this has happened i have games on
the opposite side
where i have been the one um
you know basically sticking pieces on
really really good outpost thank you
lindsay for your support really
appreciate it yeah
and i'm finishing up in five minutes
anyway okay
so for that reason this was bad for
black let's go back to the speed run
and uh just the last couple of things
basically um after bishop f4 g5 queen
takes him i mean he blunders a
a rook but it doesn't matter he's
already in huge trouble because
because he cannot get his bishop out and
queen takes g7 is coming in
and the game is over okay so that is
just i mean this is just terrible for
black and my plan here is perhaps to
stick the knight on d5 or open up the
center
there's a bunch of things that white can
do here to end the game and the rest is
very simple
here he loses his his knight and the
game is over guys
yes this will be uploaded i am already
uploading
um my editor has already uploaded
big shout out to him the first three
parts of the speed run
um broken down into into bite-sized
portions
going forward the segments are going to
be 30 to 45 minutes long because
otherwise the speed run is going to be a
very
very
long one otherwise we're going to have
800 parts
i don't want to do that but the first
three segments the first three games
have been
uploaded to youtube loving the support
on twitch but if
you want to subscribe to youtube i try
to upload as much content as possible
and uh i would really really appreciate
it thank you guys so very much for all
the hype
okay i got time for one last game
one last game and then we're gonna go
over it and wrap
up okay ready guys
no i am just a mere mortal figuring
things out just like everybody
okay i happen to be very passionate
about this but you guys make it possible
so let's go
e4 let's actually let's go d4 let's go
d4
and i'm gonna play something a little
bit different okay whoa
and it's paying off already
it's paying off already whoa okay so i
have a funny move here
i have a funny move here i have no idea
what this guy is doing
i actually can not move yeah i can play
for
i can play e4 oh my god
jeez relax what can i do now
this guy's going to get what he's what
he's looking for this guy is going to
get exactly what he's looking for how do
i attack the spawn
how do i attack this yeah i should be
too
i don't know what he's doing but he's
landing himself in a little bit of
trouble
this guy's landing himself in a little
bit of trouble and if he takes my bishop
i take on h5 and this is checkmate in
two moves
yeah now watch him start playing really
well this is like a gambit that he's
analyzed
you know for many many years but again
okay so he he actually stops mate
but we can still take the pun we're up
two pawns and we're getting his king out
into the open i mean could you possibly
ask for more out of five moves
what do we do now what do we do now and
you got to be careful guys
where do we move the bishop be careful
because remember
he wants to take on d4
and if we take back with the queen the
bishop on h5
is going to be lost so we need to move
the bishop on e3
to lend another protector for the pawn
on d4 there's no reason
it wouldn't be a disaster to get that
pawn up but why why should we
so we prepared to recapture and deform
the bishop that's that's basically
the idea here okay that is basically the
idea here
and then we basically take one to four
yeah
okay go to z6 um
there are several approaches here and
i'm going to make a move that looks very
lit well actually no let's develop a
piece that we know we want to develop
what should we develop and be careful
please because the move knight f3 would
be a blunder
we want to go knight c3 because now
we're actually threatening knight c5
that's almost checkmate so this is going
to be fun
the move that i thought about playing
and we're actually going to play this
move here
here's the thing guys i want to develop
this knight but this bishop is a pain in
the neck right now
can we get this bishop somewhere safe so
that we can complete our development
there are several possibilities so we
can try to trade this bishop we can get
it back what can we do can you give me
one move
yeah there should be two so i'm gonna go
bishop e2 to illustrate that sometimes
it's okay to have a bishop on e2 yes the
bishop is not super active
but we have extra two pawns he has a
king on e7
it's totally fine for one of one or more
of your pieces to be on a quiet passive
square
provided that you have a good reason to
put it there okay bishop h6
no reason not to trade let's take it and
let's continue our development after
that with knight f3
yeah let's just continue our development
now think about which side you want to
cast on
which side do you think white should
castle this is actually a really
instructive question
that is going to be important to as well
remember he no longer has these two
pawns
which means that if we were to castle
king's side he would be ready made to
start attacking we would justify his
strategy
we would castle long so let's prepare it
again we ignore the knight
most people would go h3 here but i want
to and so would i
but i want to emphasize that a knight on
g4 doesn't actually always do anything
but
we don't want to castle long just yet
because we would drop the pawn on f2
with a fork
so before we cast along we do want to
get rid of the night but only because
we're preparing to castle
only because we're preparing to castle
um not because that night is actually
doing anything so let's get rid of the
night are we threatening to capture the
night
are we threatening to capture the night
here well we actually were not
but we would have moved the rook away
now we're ready to cast along we
actually aren't but we would have
moved the rook away and then we would
have been threatening to capture the
night
yeah we can actually take this night
that's also possible but remember what i
tell you guys
it's less important to ruin his fond
structure it's more important to ruin
the structure around his king
okay let's get this out of here even
though it's not doing anything there so
bishop takes a6 doesn't actually ruin
the structure around his king
i would not actually do that because it
also opens up the b file it helps him
attack
what do we do in such positions the time
has come to open the center
do we have a way to open the center guys
we don't we don't even need g4g5
we have a ready-made way to open the
center nope guys don't play d5 that is
exactly what you want to avoid here
just take the pawn just take the pawn
open the d-file
take the pawn open up the center and we
have already born the fruits of it now
he's taking f65 we ask ourselves
immediately
what are the drawbacks of the move he
has weakened the square
let's find a tactic together what is
this called
guys and i told you guys to pay
attention to this what is this called
the rook and the queen are in what
relationship an x-ray
what do we look for when we have an
x-ray we look for a discovery if we move
this queen away
and if this pawn were gone from d6 we
would be winning his queen
so what move can we make to make both of
these things happen
what is the tactic bingo knight takes e5
if d takes e5
we just give a check that's it we want
to screen that's the importance of
paying attention to these tactics
and the game is over the game is
literally over because
not only does he lose his queen it gets
checkmated while he is at it
i'm not trying to pretend that it is
easy to find tactics of all kinds
but when you are aware when you are
tactically aware
it becomes a lot easier to spot these
hidden tactics that is one of the
drawbacks of solving puzzles
you know that there is a tactic trivia
question we have checkmate in two moves
we actually can make a move before
taking the queen that leads to checkmate
and two
find it what is the move
no we can take the queen and the rook
normally i would
propose for that to happen but check
let's get a piece on f7 to block the
king's escape
and now this is checkmate we could have
also taken the pinch very quickly
because i have to go in three minutes
let's analyze okay
g5 is obviously terrible it's also
terrible after e4 i have faced the move
once and i'll talk later about it
um i'll talk later about it i'm just
going to write this down
but um we didn't do anything
extraordinary the movie 4 is very nice
because
we prepare to give checkmate okay so
this is all very very simple bishop e2
we are threatening to take on h5 with
checkmate
and the key moment in the game that i
want you guys to pay very careful
attention to the move this should be two
it doesn't look like anything
but it's actually a very important move
we
the bishop has done its job we drop it
back to prepare
the continued development we bring all
our pieces out we don't do anything
crazy we don't go g4
we simply develop we castle long in
order to
not give him an attack had he done
something like this we could have just
moved our rook out of the way
and in addition to in addition to
just is there doing anything here or is
it just staring at the pawn
hint it's actually doing something on g1
what is it doing
it is not actually staring at the pawn
it might supervise a potential g4 but
didn't you say daniel that you shouldn't
do this i'm not saying that i'm just
saying d take c5 is a simpler way to
open the center but if we do
choose to pawn storm we might have a
rook poised
to exploit the opening of the file okay
instead he does our work for us we get
the night out
d takes e5 and here already at this
point
as soon as we castle i am already
noticing the x-ray
and by noticing the x-ray it becomes a
lot easier to find a tactic like this
because we simply apply the logical
steps to make this x-ray into a discover
check what do we need
we need to get rid of the spawn distract
it we need to get rid of the screen
the best way to get rid of one of our
own pieces is to do so with check
we have a check and we have a way to get
rid of his pawn he shouldn't have taken
the knight but it wouldn't have mattered
and now we find the best move simple
effective unoriginal we just do
stuff that we know to do we develop our
pieces measured
solid thought through chest no drastic
movements that is how you beat offbeat
openings